hi welcome back to our series on
qualitative research methods I'm Leslie
curry from the Yale School of Public
Health and this module is on a major
qualitative study design focus groups
just a brief overview of the modules the
goal is to enhance our capacity to
conceptualize design and conduct
qualitative research in the Health
Sciences there are total of six modules
in this series and this module examines
the major qualitative study design focus
groups so what is a focus group in this
picture you see a group of individuals
sitting in a circle in a room and some
conversation happening a focus group is
a group of people with certain
characteristics who generate narrative
data in a focused discussion the
interaction and the group dynamics are
really essential the interaction among
individuals can do several things it can
widen the range of responses we're
hearing from a range of individuals with
a common experience but of course
different individual perspectives and
views the group dynamics can activate
forgotten details
hearing someone recount a story of their
experience might help another remember
you know this happened to me and the
group exchange can also release
inhibitions can make people feel
comfortable in describing their
experience with a particular phenomenon
focus groups can be useful for a number
of kinds of topics and the Health
Sciences the first characterizing social
and cultural norms around a given health
area health behavior or type of
healthcare delivery focus groups can be
useful for sharing and comparing really
like this phrase by David Morgan who's
the author of the focus group kit and
who describes sharing and comparing as
the dynamic in the group where each
member will offer up their perspective
and in that context in the discussion
comparing their experience
with with others in the room this can
generate insights that wouldn't be
possible on in a one-on-one exchange
focus groups can reveal how people talk
about an issue because people are
sitting around a table and exchanging
amongst themselves the researcher
moderator can listen and learn the kinds
of language people use their intonation
their views about a given issue focus
groups can also be useful for exploring
potentially sensitive topics we
mentioned this in the individual
interview module as well and so it
really is dependent on the particular
topic and the respondent group that
you'll be working with to determine
whether or not individual one-on-one
interview format would be most
appropriate or whether a group format is
most appropriate given your topic so a
few a few minutes on designing focus
group studies what do they look like
well there are some standards for the
group size and number in focus groups so
the principle one in terms of group size
is that you want to have five to ten
participants per group fewer than five
typically the dynamics are flatter there
isn't as much momentum in the group
maybe not as much speak and freedom when
you have small group exchange and more
than ten participants it is very
difficult for the moderator to keep the
discussion moving flowing well and for
each participant to have enough time to
express substantively their view on a
given topic so the range of five to ten
is a guide guideline and the second
guideline is the number of focus groups
per strata we typically recommend having
three to five groups per strata so just
a minute on stratification if you
determine that a given topic may
generate some tension or difficulty if
it's addressed say with a group of mixed
gender you may decide that it's
important to have focus groups of with
all women and a separate set of focus
groups with all men and if that occurs
you need to be sure that you kind
three groups a minimum of three groups
of women and a minimum of three groups
of men so group composition attention to
group composition really very critical
there are a number of ways we can think
about assembling focus groups and they
really depend in great to great lengths
on the nature of the question that
you're asking so several considerations
we want to avoid power differentials in
the room among individuals so for
instance if you were conducting a study
about culture change in nursing homes
the pioneering effort to individualize
care and nursing homes by which
residents express their needs and
certified nurse assistants and nurse
aides are free to deviate from schedules
in order to respond to a resident
preference or need you would want to be
mindful of having a focus group with the
certified nursing assistants or Nurse
Aides together with for instance the
charge nurse or the nursing home
administrator you could imagine that the
dynamic in that room would really could
really inhibit free exchange so be
mindful of power differentials in the
room thinking about homogeneity and
heterogeneity in the group how alike do
you want the group to be and how
different do you want the group to be
we're looking for some diversity so that
you have a range of opinions and yet you
don't want to want to also have
homogeneity or similarity in the group
so that there is enough common ground to
share and compare strangers versus
acquaintances is another consideration
the composition of groups are you
interested in having people who have
never had an exchange with one another
or is it more appropriate in a given
circumstance to have acquaintances those
who have some familiarity with each
other experts and novices are we looking
to talk to experts in a given area who
have deep knowledge of a phenomenon or
are we looking for more naive view and
then stratifying by these saline
characteristics as I mentioned it may be
gender in a given group where you want
to pay attention to those potential
dynamics and create separate strata for
those groups data collection I like this
image because to me it sort of tells all
we need to know about
data collection and focus groups the
idea is to just drop a pebble into the
pond and to stimulate a ripple effect of
conversation the discussion guide there
are some there's some guidance some
established techniques for structuring
discussion guides in general the number
of questions we're looking for no more
than eight to twelve questions
fewer is better it's helpful to kind of
labeled questions as five or ten-minute
questions one that the researcher comes
in and thinks I don't want them to spend
too much more than five minutes on this
it's a relevant topic that's introducing
them bringing them to the core issue the
10-minute question is where I really
want them to linger and have deeper
discussion the sequence of questions are
also some guidelines they're the opening
questions should be things that could be
answered quickly that are based on facts
you want the individual to use their
voice to not be threatened not have a
tricky question to establish them as the
expert right so there's one answer and
they know it so opening questions are
really very useful for setting the stage
in the room an introductory question is
to begin to foster interaction among the
group and have them begin to focus on
the topic at hand transition questions
link the introduction to the real key
questions and begin to put the topic in
context so you're moving people some
sort of the broad comfort establishing
questions into the core the core topic
at hand and there should be no more than
two to five key questions in the guide
so item writing just some things to keep
in mind
conversational clear simple language
sometimes as researchers we sit in our
teams and we construct these complex
compound sentences that are our
questions for our discussion guide and
when you speak them out loud only then
you can hear maybe how how silly they
sound or potentially off-putting so read
them aloud practice them see whether
they in fact feel conversational and
clear open-ended questions are critical
again not leading in any way having very
broad parameters for the respondents to
begin to generate and shape the
direction of the
discussion the think back technique can
be really very useful asking people to
think back to the last time when you
were at the doctor's office it brings
them out of the room back to a time in
place it grounds them in an experience
where they feel then they can draw upon
details that are relevant to the
discussion so that can be useful avoid
if possible asking why this may seem
counterintuitive this is what we're
trying to understand why don't you do X
or Y we don't want to ask this question
so boldly and directly it's very
sharpened tone it may cause
defensiveness it may make the respondent
feel like there must be a right answer
and I better give that right answer so
in fact we want to avoid the Y question
instead we we want to invite people to
comment on how something happens or to
describe their experience in detail we
also want to avoid giving examples this
may lead participants sometimes this
technique can be useful to give a very
brief example to sort of get people
going but it also runs the risk of
leading participants down a particular
path so be cautious on the examples be
aware of the participants time there are
limits of all types the time limits to
attention limits to language various
cultural issues and various
communication skills we for instance
have done lots of focus groups with
frail older adults in the community and
bringing them to common spaces libraries
and community centers to talk about
services that they're receiving in their
homes and we need to be very mindful of
their physical comfort their ability to
stay engaged in a conversation the
communication skills from the researcher
to populations who may not be familiar
necessarily or customed to being in
research environments so these
sensitivities are really very very
critical in conducting focus focus
groups moderator skills moderating focus
groups requires a great deal of skill
and really the only way to attain these
skills is to practice moderating but
there are some techniques that are
really very critical to facilitating
constructive and productive discussions
the
first is having a strong interviewing
technique this means the ability to ask
an open question and to receive the
information to listen acutely for
opportunities to dig deeper so having
these keen observational skills watching
what's happening in the room you can
imagine in the moment you know you have
eight people sitting around a table
you're beginning to just drop that
pebble so there's a ripple effect and
the conversation starts
you're very tuned to the dynamics in the
group this is one of the unique assets
of a focus group model and so keen
observational skills watch who's
speaking first who's listening who's
leaning forward who's pulling back it's
really very very critical need to have
an ability to control and guide the
discussion
this requires in the moment judgment
again we've you think back to the
interviewer module where we have the
image of a path with a railing kind of
going through a marsh you want to be
able to let the respondent let the group
conversation go and yet you also need to
control it and guide it without
prematurely truncating conversation this
is very tricky and has to be assessed in
the moment need an ability to suppress
our own personal views this perhaps
easier than it sounds we're often you
know researching a topic that is of
great interest to us we probably have
personal views but we need to be really
very neutral in the role of moderator
and lastly again respect for the
participants so active listening leaning
forward paying attention not scribbling
notes or looking at the tape recorder or
watching the time go by watching the
clock you know active listening I
contact with each individual concern for
their comfort in the space respect for
participants is really also very
important to establishing a safe space
for the data collection so we're going
to listen to an excerpt from a focus
group and listen carefully really to the
moderator some of the audio you'll hear
multiple members speaking at once but
listen for the moderators voice
then we'll review what you've heard so
let's listen we're not going to go run
the circle anymore we just need to just
join in whenever you have something to
say um what to you all makes a good
doctor what what does it take to be a
good doctor would you say one that lets
you marry says okay that would you think
I mean okay and what else about a doctor
makes a good doctor in the office okay
and how would the doctor do that well
how would he show that I don't think you
pissed or didn't even think about your
problem yeah any other thoughts about
what makes a good doctor maybe watching
you
Jenny you know not not touching you all
over but you know like nice studying and
that's very good and over here
feels good with that oh nice version out
kind of Dorothy what do you mean by that
nice personality well I'm saying I think
you guys show that they are interested
in you you know okay
giving the ideas of how they might show
how they're interested okay so what did
you hear there several things happening
at once you hear the moderator
interjecting saying Mary what do you
think is that what you think Emily so
identifying speakers this is important
for really the sort of mechanics of
generating a data set for focus groups
the transcriptionist has to be able to
identify a given voice with a name some
identification so that you're able to
understand which person is speaking at
what time and your Libby to look at
patterns of speech across members in the
group so being able to tag a specific
name or identification to a voice is
really critical for transcription and in
the moderating we often we instruct
people in the group before you speak
please say your name this isn't a very
natural thing for us to do and so
participants often will just begin
talking and so the moderator can sort of
quietly interject you know meri said
this and did you hear that is that what
you said Emily you hear in this in this
excerpt an icebreaker question something
very open easy you know what does a
doctor what does what does it take to be
a good doctor
and you can hear the respondents feeling
confident in describing you know I want
one who you know pays attention to me
one who you know is close in the
interactions who knows your name do you
hear the moderator asking clarifying
probes what do you mean by that nice
personality asking for just a little
more about you you know what the
respondent means when she's describing
nice personality and then lastly you can
hear the very dynamic exchanges in the
group where individuals are starting
this is very early in the group and you
can hear them already starting to
reflect back and forth across each other
so just to give you a sense of what the
dynamic interplay might sound like in a
focus group analysis of focus group data
this is an area where I think we often
fall short there are some assumptions we
may come to the data thinking well it's
just a bunch of individual will analyze
it like individual interviews which
loses the richness of the group dynamic
and in fact doesn't pay attention to
some of the critical aspects of focus
group data which is sort of the group
interaction and so analysis of focus
group data requires careful attention to
several things we have to remember that
the group is the unit of analysis not
the individuals within it and so we're
looking to extract the summary of
emerging ideas and themes at the group
level not individual utterances within
the text so just a mindful as we're
approaching the data we want to be
looking for whether or not a theme is a
view of one member or whether it was a
theme for the group was it really only
one participant who felt a given way or
expressed a particular experience or
perspective or was this one where there
developed some consensus or
some shared view throughout the group
discussion we want to know whether
question whether a response emerged as a
result of a question led by the
moderator or whether it was something
that spontaneously came from the group
conversation we want to note that more
text does not mean the issue is more
important necessarily there may be some
very brief text on something there was
great agreement very quickly and so we
don't want to be sort of way distracted
into thinking that if there's a lot of
conversation about something it means
it's really the essence of the study and
so looking at the dynamics in the group
really very critical throughout
throughout the group is there biasing is
there groupthink is there a single
member who dominates the discussion so
several tips for a good focus group
creating rapport among the group members
first this is in contrast to individual
interviews where it's really very much
about the interviewer and the respondent
and establishing that space for candor
and disclosure right up front in this
instance the moderator wants to be very
very light almost invisible in the room
off to the side and really focusing on
the relationship among the members is is
the primary goal in creating a
relationship among them in the first
moments of the group is the is the
primary primary goal establishing a safe
space
knowing how to make hesitant people feel
comfortable in contributing in that
space really also can be very useful
being prepared to redirect the group so
listening very very carefully and
letting the group sort of take itself
down a certain path but not too far and
being ready to interject without
squelching the dynamics this is tricky
we we want to bring the group around
gently back to the topic at hand and not
interject with too much control because
that can sort of deflate the momentum in
a group so be careful managing the
dynamics in the room so there are always
dynamics and every
that we experienced focus groups is no
different and so there will be people
who feel more confident who are more
vocal who have stronger opinions there
will be others who are more hesitant and
maybe feel more anxious in the group
space and so managing those dynamics
really is something the moderator is
responsible for from the moment the
group begins through to the end because
the domineering dynamics can constrain
conversation and the sort of repeated
interjection of a given prospective of
you can also bias the dialogue so
managing those dynamics is really very
important lastly one of the benefits of
focus groups is that we're getting to
watch people as well so being aware of
the nonverbal information in the room
and there's lots of it in our focus
group work we have a primary moderator
who's responsible for sort of dropping
that pebble and then facilitating the
conversation as it goes and we have a
second person in the room who is doing
managing all the logistics so that
they're unobtrusive and taking careful
note of nonverbal information in the
room who pulls away from the table who
seems to be aggressive who is nodding in
deference all the time to another
respondent and those kinds of nonverbal
data are really very useful in
interpretation again of the group
findings and with the group as a unit of
analysis thank you for your attention